so the nra the national rifle
association has filed for bankruptcy but
before you get your hopes up recognize
that this is
chapter 11 bankruptcy a chapter 11
bankruptcy is a kind of reorganization
that
attempts to pay off the creditors and
allow the
company or firm to continue as a going
forward concern now that being said it
can be used as a potential shield
against litigation or at least to delay
litigation and
the nra has filed for bankruptcy in
texas
probably seeking a more favorable venue
than new york where they're currently
being sued by
attorney general tish james who has
vowed to basically sue them
out of existence but it will be
interesting to see what happens here
because the nra is made up of many
different organizations
one of which the original is chartered
in new york but those assets may be
folded into some of the other nra
related affiliates so the nra is not
going anywhere at the moment
so stay tuned for more legal analysis
and i'll see you in court